I let's say just for me I always loved
Lucy and Tom together thanks um too you
know I like that Lucy got Tom but also
called Tom out on his
um kind of kept him on his toes I also
thought that
um I I don't know I think that he made
Lucy's character interesting and like I
think she liked to be surprised by all
the fun that he would bring how was it
the two that when you guys when those
two characters got together how how well
you know what's interesting is that I
was a huge fan of the show before I was
on it and so when I got the audition for
it I was like I was like oh my God a
similar to Abby's I was like I need this
job how do I get this job and then I was
like
what woman in her right mind
would like this man
go on and so then I was like I I have to
find who this might be
because like what on Earth and when you
were auditioning did you know it was
recurring or did you think it was a one
and done I knew it was I think two at
least two episodes or three something
like that I didn't know if it would be
brought back for more and uh listeners
of this podcast we're not going to tell
you if it's more that's right that's
right stay tuned some of you don't know
what's coming and we're not gonna tell
you yeah and so what I did little known
fact what I did when I auditioned is I I
did all my lines in an Aziz impression
because I thought the only person who
would like him is someone who's exactly
like that stuff I was like I was like
hello
you know I I I literally did all my
lines like that yes and then I got the
job and they were like you were so great
don't do that
that instinct you had got you the job
but don't do not do that and so then I I
basically
um
had the same attitude but but without
without the yeah without the full
impression of him and and I and I was
like this is I think this is just
somebody who
um who likes the ambition and the
surprise and the like this is a small
town and there's not anybody like Tom in
this town you know and and so I think
that like that was what was
connecting for them too and what kind of
kept bringing them back yeah together
yeah um so yeah I really I mean it was
it's honestly like it like I said it was
it was my favorite show before I was on
it and I I it was a dream of a lifetime
to be on it and and like it's still it
still is it's like I I I I walk down the
street and people are like Lucy and I
love it so much and I and I just really
it makes me so it's like one of the
proudest moments of my life and of my
career yeah it truly is Jim walks down
the street no one Paces
I'm Jerry Gary Jerry Larry I've always
wondered if people were a little mean to
you in the spirit of Jerry or gay I will
say it's just the opposite really oh
it's almost if they only knew me I mean
like they're so nice to me
like because they think I'm Jerry yeah
and yeah that's love I mean please be
that nice but I love that you
love love the show oh I mean I who
doesn't obviously but like I I just
following on a million shows over the
years no it's so special not great he
barely works but the rest of us who work
a lot he got me out of cryosleep for
this podcast great yeah no but you know
what I here's what I loved about Parks I
mean so many things but one of the
things I loved and this was just the
people came together we didn't really
all know I mean most of us didn't know
each other before the show starts I've
been on shows where you're guesting for
example and you're kind of the outsider
you're the you're guesting and no one
gives you hello goodbye good morning
like it Parks if you hadn't been on that
if we hadn't Met You Yet everyone's
going to come up to you yeah so sweet it
was just that and not that anyone told
us to do it it was just called kindness
and Amy said a tone that was
love and laughter yeah like during in
Mike said a tone with you know totally
at the top of the rung with you know
writers and everything so yeah I love
when people say that because it was it
was truly amazing and I felt you know
very as a guest star also you you
sometimes don't
get to like people just want you to do
one thing and they don't let you play or
do anything different or so and Mike's
very open to and respectful of artists
and people doing doing their stuff so I
felt very
um empowered on that show and also we we
haven't we talked about him at the
beginning of this but Dean Holland who
directed this episode who was a long
time editor on Parks and who
um is a brilliant director is so great
he's such a great director and he's such
a great person and we became friends
doing this show and like
um I just I just I just remember like
when I was watching this episode this
morning I was thinking about Dean doing
this episode and it was just he's he's
the best it was just such a wonderful
experience and also like you know I
think most shows especially shows that
go on this long
um have an intimate relationship with
their crew and their and their cameramen
and this show I think everyone was so
happy to be on it that it was like a
little even deeper than that and
especially with the with the whole
camera team which was like almost part
of the show yeah yeah it's just like you
know documentary style thing where
people are just like in there with you
and trying and working with the actor
specifically to get looks and reactions
and and things like that so it I still
see people from the crew around and like
you said it's been 12 years and and I'm
so like oh wait what's that like it's
very it's very exciting and that's not
something you often get as a guest star
on something
um but it was yeah you're right the
guest stars a lot of times
come in here's what you auditioned for
you gave us that in the room give it to
us again today and move on like and
that's fine I've been I've done that
many times but yeah I think Parks did
open things up and I just had lunch
recently with uh Shauna Hagan who is
where we got the name tweep yeah the
camera yeah I just had lunch with her in
like I don't know two or three weeks ago
really camera woman yeah woman she's
doing tons of documentaries and uh my
boys you know like Tom McGill who DP'd
the last how many seasons yeah he's one
of my boys I mean yes lifelong
friendships yeah lifelong friendships